Well, it's important because
it's knowledge, the knowledge
of numbers.
The algebraic numbers are the
ones that we're the most
familiar with.
But in a sense, there's hardly
any of them compared to
transcendental numbers.
Algebraic numbers are actually
countable, or listable is
another way of saying it.
So it's actually quite
a small infinity.
It's the smallest infinity.
But on the real number line,
you've got a bigger infinite.
It just so happens that most
of the numbers on the real
number line are transcendental.
And we didn't know that
until we discovered
transcendental numbers.
So this is really recent
information in terms of the
long history of maths that
humanity's been covering over
2,000 years.
This is a new fact.
And what this meant, the
transcendence of pi--
I like that, the transcendence
of pi--
actually answered some really
interesting questions.
There were some really old
questions that the Greeks had
about squaring the circle, so
how can you make a circle of a
particular area, turn
that into a square.
And there was lots of ways that
they tried to do it with
straight edge and compass.
But all those things, every
attempt they do, actually ends
up being an algebraic
equation, right?
So they were saying how
can we turn pi-- so pi
is linked in there.
How can we turn pi into another
thing by using algebra?
Well, it just shows that
you can't because it's
transcendental.
There's something really
tricky going on.
And that's why I like it,
because the tricky stuff is
where all the awesome
maths is.
Well, the thing is, with pi,
pi is about perfection.
And there are no perfect circles
in our universe.
None.
So you don't need pi per se.
You can get by with 3.14, or
29 digits to do the biggest
theoretical ring around
the universe or
something like that.
And anything that truncates,
like any decimal that ends, is
a fraction because it's just
that number divided by 1 with
how many zeroes.
And so dealing with fractions,
fractions, we know how to deal
with fractions.
There's a difference between
dealing with big numbers and
dealing with these very
strange numbers.
But see, this stuff is just
to do with maths.
But just to show you the power
of it, the construction of,
say, Euler's identity, this
thing is all hanging together
with infinitely sharp
perfection.
It's not a number near e
or a number near pi.
These are the numbers,
and there is a
specific value for that.
So it's really, really
important we get
these things right.
In maths, perfection
is important.
But then, anyone who uses maths
for physics or chemistry
or whatever you want to do,
then they can kind of use
approximations.
I'm not interested in